baby  let's go  just make sure you hold your finish just  trying to help you out bro  so I know you've been playing for me for  a while but you should know better than  to have your thumb in your ass write it  out a little longer know what to do  let's go let's go coach Luke you're  right get the [ __ ] up cheers got us a  new DeShaun Watson that's what I like to  see man  bro I don't even know go after Z come on  come on Hey sir let me holla at you real  quick understand hey Zach understand I  don't care about your little [ __ ] ass I  don't care if you guys look good for  your mama cause your daddy left I got a  family I gotta worry about it don't make  no sense I got a 34 year old daughter oh  my God take care of  fix it  you gonna play for me son you understand  we gonna win with you